Speaker 1: Let's go to Marcus from Florida,
Marcus from Florida.
You are next on today.
Speaker 5: Hey, Dave.
Hey.
I've been I've just been hearing you about
some candidates that could be, you know, for
for election in 2024.
Yeah, I think they got to be related to the
Jan. six committee because they're going to
pick a Republican.
That's all crazy supporting Jan. six.
And it will be great if one or one of them
will be a candidate for the Democrats now.
Jamie Raskin is my favorite.
He's got great comebacks and he's really knowledgeable
and he's got a bunch of support from different
groups.
And, you know, I'm not sure what religion
he is.
He is, but I even have support from non-religious
people.
Well, here's
Speaker 1: the thing with Raskin, Markos.
So let let me make mention I think Jamie Raskin
is extremely smart.
Fantastic public speaker has done an incredible
job with the Trump impeachment, you know,
years ago, and I think he's a fascinating
guy.
I think that he is going to have an issue
because he is Jewish.
I think that there are people who don't want,
I mean, there's anti-Semitism in the U.S.,
on the right and on the left.
And I think Jamie Raskin, among other reasons,
may have a little bit of an uphill battle
because he is Jewish.
But I think he's an interesting guy.
I just don't I just don't see him as even
running, to be perfectly honest.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I think Jamie is as Jewish
for a race, but not necessarily a Jewish believer.
Speaker 1: Well, you know, you've opened up
a very important question.
That's a that's the vast majority of Jews.
I mean, the Jews in the United States who
are, of course, ethnically Jewish.
As you're pointing out, many don't literally
believe the teachings I am.
I am one such person.
You know, I'm not a religious person at all,
but I identify with the Jewish community and
ethnicity and culture.
Yeah, no, you're right.
The problem is the anti-Semites don't care
about that.
Speaker 5: Right.
Indeed.
The other question real quick is about Florida,
it's all a bunch of stuff going on in Florida.
Yeah, whether they're banning boats from the
schools, yes, they're now, they're got Nazis
all over the place.
And the Republican Party is not saying anything
about it.
Basically, I'm worried about.
We already have Christian nationalist in the
military.
Yes.
You know, Michael Flynn was just one of them.
And it's going on as well.
And now we got Nazi.
So maybe they're in the military.
And it could be pretty bad.
Yeah, you know, the banning of books is similar
to what happened in Germany when they burned
books because they were on German.
And now they're doing books because they're
not white or they're not religious.
The school board said something last week
about in my area, about saying, Well, if you
can't read, you know, a book and in in charge,
you shouldn't have it in your library.
You know, that's pretty bad.
Speaker 1: That is pretty bad.
It's horrible.
What's going on in Florida?
The other thing you didn't mention, which
we talked about earlier this week on the bonus
show is that they're moving this don't say
gay bill through the Senate, where teachers
in primary school won't be allowed to even
talk at all about sexual orientation or gender
identity.
And we, of course, understand the homophobic
and transphobic nature of that.
It's wacky what's going on in Florida?
I'm actually I have a couple of invitations
for shows that film in Florida, and I'm thinking
now that COVID cases are down so low, I may
do it soon.
So I may be down there doing a little investigating
of my own before you know it.
Speaker 5: Well, let me know when you come
by, maybe we will meet.
Speaker 1: All right, yeah, we'll grab an
espresso, OK?
Thank you.
Very good, there's Marcus from Florida.
Yeah, I mean, it's it's a covert hellscape,
but the weather is nice